thousands also flocking to the las vegas
strip to check out the red carpet stage
right in front of the bellagio it was
really a terrific place to see all the
action first hand sasha loftus has been
down at mona mega bee at the paris hotel
and casino all week she is still there
joining us now live with more sasha
yes brian that draft event here on the
strip is winding down but of course it
is the las vegas strip on a friday night
so it is still very busy those we spoke
with tonight say that they got here on
thursday and they're staying through the
whole weekend to get that entire
experience
day two of the nfl draft and the fun
just keeps on coming this is awesome
once in a lifetime experience visitors
and southern nevadans packed the las
vegas strip friday to get a glimpse of
all the action it's amazing i'm a big
jess fan
very hopeful
not very optimistic the roads stayed
closed in front of the red carpet stage
on the bellagio lake
[Music]
so the thousands down here could move
where they wanted
but a lot more metro officers were out
in full force along with firefighters
and paramedics to keep everyone safe
[Music]
there we go many are so glad to finally
be here after the event was canceled due
to covid two years ago that was my
biggest disappointment at the whole kobe
thing was missing this
so i'm glad we got a chance to come back
adding that they jumped on the
opportunity to rebook their trip for
this week and feel a real sense of
normalcy again coming out of a two-year
covid
and to be in lockdown in houses this is
amazing grateful to celebrate one of the
biggest sports events of the year it's
amazing there's so many things going on
in this city that knows how to throw a
party it's always amazing to be here
las vegas boulevard is still closed
between bellagio drive and flamingo it
will stay closed for about another hour
until 11 59 p.m crews are cleaning it up
right now before they reopen it to
traffic reporting live tonight sasha
loftis live local now